D
STEVE.
PEOPLE NEED TO SEE THIS.
IT'S GOING TO FAR AND IT'S
GETTING SCARY.
PAUL VAUGHN, WHO WAS WERE
ARRESTED IN FRONT OF HIS MANY
CHILDREN JOIN US NOW, AND HIS
ATTORNEY PETER GREEN.
THANK YOU BOTH VERY MUCH.
PAUL FIRST YOU.
I HAVE TO WONDER, WHAT DID YOUR
CHILDREN THINK OF THIS?
>> WELL, TUCKER, THEY'RE TRYING
TO PROCESS AND WORK THROUGH IT
HAPPENED.
FORTUNATELY AS A CHRISTIAN
FAMILY WE DO A LOT OF STUDYING
ABOUT HIS START CHRISTIANITY IN
MISSIONARIES AND PERSECUTION, SO
THERE FAMILIAR WITH THE STORIES.
THEY KNOW ABOUT PEOPLE MARTYRED
THROUGHOUT HISTORY, PERSECUTED
AND PICKED ON BY BULLIED TYRANTS
AND OTHER PARTS OF HISTORY JUST
LIKE IN AMERICA TODAY.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO UNLEASH THE FBI ON AN
ENTIRE RELIGION, ARE YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I DON'T THINK THAT BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN TRAINED IT MAKES IT
OKAY.
WHEN MY KIDS GOT TO THE CAR TO
GO TO SCHOOL, AND THE FBI PULLS
UP, ARMED, RUNNING TO THE DOOR
AND ONE OF THEM GHOST KIDS, AND
HOLDS THE KIDS WITH A LONG GUN,
ON THE SIDE OF MY DRIVEWAY AND
DOES NOT LET THEM GO INTO THE
HOUSE, THAT'S ABSOLUTELY, AS MY
WIFE SAYS ON THE VIDEO,
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Tucker: IT'S ONE OF THOSE
SHOCKING THINGS I'VE EVER SEEN.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU, THE FBI, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, IS
CLAIMING YOUR VIOLENT EXTREMIST
WHO IS A PHYSICAL THREAT TO
OTHERS.
DO YOU EMBRACE VIOLENCE?
HAVE YOU EVER COMMITTED
VIOLENCE?
WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
IT IS NO EVIDENCE OF THAT.
THE ONLY PLACE THAT'S EVER SEEN
IS IN THE DOCUMENTS THEY MADE UP
AND USED TO JUSTIFY IN THEIR
MIND AND TO THE JUSTICE SYSTEM,
THE ONES WHO SIGNED UP FOR THIS
NEED SOME JUSTIFICATION IN THEIR
OWN MINDS TO GO AFTER PEACEFUL
PEOPLE WHO DISAGREED WITH THEM
POLITICALLY.
>> Tucker: PETER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR WORKING ON THIS CASE
AND DEFENDING PAUL VAUGHN.
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS IS
ACTUALLY CAN GO TO TRIAL?
>> WELL, TUCKER, WHEN YOU'VE GOT
A FEDERAL PROMISE PROSECUTOR
AFTER THAT.
PAUL WASN'T EVEN ARRESTED BY THE
LOCAL POLICE FOR TRESPASSING.
BUT THOSE WHO DID, WHO WERE
ARRESTED, WE ARE LEANING ON THE
TRADITION OF
DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING.
HE HIMSELF WAS INSPIRED BY
MAHATMA GANDHI.
THIS IS THE GREAT TRADITION OF
AMERICAN CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE AND
IT'S NOT THE SORT OF THING THAT
YOU TURN INTO A 10-YEAR FELONY.
PAUL AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
STRONG DEFENSE AND WE HOPE TO
BEAT THESE CHARGES AT TRIAL.
>> Tucker: AND I HOPE YOU DO
SO WITH A COUNTRY THAT RISES UP
ON YOUR SIDE THAT HE WASN'T EVEN
ARRESTED FOR TRESPASSING ON THE
SCENE, AND A YEAR LATER THEY